he was on his knees in the alley in the
back there standing like God is ear off
cut his ear off - shortening yes yeah I
mean I want to do it but you know here
all yelling so I just like it man I
could hear often
not happening I'm your host Ari Shaffir
and today the topic is crime you might
know him from his popular podcast on
Sirius and iTunes called race Wars
please give it up for mr. Kurt Metzger
everyone I'm really torn because he was
gonna be a rabbi and I was a minute I
actually wasn't Minister I was a
Jehovah's Witness and I was born into it
is anybody raised religious in here this
is two different stories by the way got
connect in a very weird way you are what
were you oh that's the natural vampires
versus werewolves of Java witnesses Oh
II don't like us you know idea I used to
live down south they didn't like me
because I didn't believe in Hell like
why would you get mad at me for that
well people hear it they're like oh you
can't do your birthdays and uh I don't
know Prince
those are the two things it's not
well-known it's just a regular doomsday
cult it's no big deal but I'm not bitter
against it and I you know I kind of
appreciate it you know because it really
taught me how to lie you know thank you
if you raised religious that's what it
really gives you the life skill of like
who to lie to in a way and why like you
you can't get that from a secular
education you need like higher stakes
you know to really act like your life
depends on it you know
because your immortality depends
on it so that's when you really learn
right it's valuable skill to have I'm
sure you got it in spades right you were
like what you wanted them like blow a
little of those guys yeah so that's the
you see how you learn you first you tell
yourself this is God's language that you
tell yourself that and that's reality
so other lies come easy once you know
how to do that magic right and you get
like a secret life and you know when
religious people go bad everyone jumps
on them because they think you're not
supposed to sin but it they're really
just doing everybody does is just
they built it up so much that they're
not that kind of person so that's why
it's so devastating you and your head
you're like I'm not a guy that does it's
like this right so when I grew up out of
the church I was in I realized everybody
was doing like soap opera epic just
and all kinds of crazy that
I had no idea as a kid like I'm the
sucker that followed it
I felt that because I really did you
know like I was raped I was told never
to masturbate ever like that religious
like an adult said you should never
never if all goes perfectly you will
have never masturbated don't a straight
face said that's me I know yeah you know
what happened by the way to a grown man
just medically if he never masturbated
no nobody knows it's never been
attempted by me but I'm supposed to be
the first man in history to not check my
jig on my Kurt we do you could be the
chosen one
so we've all does it we've all failed
you know yeah but it's that kind of
stuff right and so but ours was a spit
like what's especially hard about Chavez
witnesses or why what people might think
as culty is you have to do it okay
that's what made the hardest part about
the religion it's not like Catholics I
always Envy because that's like so great
you just get to be Catholic you want to
do nothing
right really gonna do you watch like
mafia movies you never see him take the
guy hey mr. soprano don't come to this
church no more because you're a murderer
you know they don't say that it's cool
we had to do ours or you get
disfellowshipped right which is like
cast out and all your friends are in the
congregation they said it's set up that
way your real friends are in your or
jobs with the rest you are nice like we
could be acquaintances but you know
God's going to exterminate you off this
earth so don't get too attached are you
seem like nice people man we didn't have
hell though but it was still all
everything on you so people would have
secret lives right so this is the first
this is about a sex crime this story and
I yeah yeah um when I was eight my
brother was born and my mom's best
friend in the in the church
her son babysat me he was 13 okay we'll
call him Josh and uh he was like he's
like an adult to me because I was eight
you know who's 13 year old when I think
back on that is funny because he was
like really skinny is the 80s oh he's
got like a Luke Skywalker butt cut kind
of hair right and he's Jeffrey
Dahmer glasses that everybody had and a
real skinny with like really high shorts
okay I know so he was just along with
him the whole day and he didn't want me
herself then we just watched her I had
to watch The Honeymooners which I didn't
care for as I was he that's not the sex
crime that it went fine we just better
day today
he's a nice church boy he wasn't um so
but a few years later he when he got to
high school he started working out a lot
this guy and uh but just his top he's
one of those dudes right and it was
before people really started calling you
on that so he really I mean he did
sterols I don't know if he just shot the
steroids on the top part like that I
don't know what it did but he just
gigantic but the same legs I remember
from 13 and it seemed here but it was
just smaller on his big steroid I know
he was a hulking man now he's like 17 I
know you everything Jesus josh is huge
like we all just very impressive right I
know then even more impressive he ended
up banging his geometry teacher yeah
this young teacher uh I guess statutory
you braved him and they didn't really
charge you back then
no they just handled it at the school
she got fired on she got divorced and
then uh it's a big scandal cuz I heard
about through the Jehovah Witness
grapevine right that was the the gossip
and uh so the developments were amazing
when they come in but then the most
amazing development was she decided she
wanted to study the Bible with Jehovah's
Witnesses so they have to let you so
that's what she said she started coming
into the church and uh you know Josh's
mom wasn't too thrilled but what she
can't say nothing about it and uh then
they got married she's studying this
over a four-year period she became a
drovers witness and a married and became
a nice Christian couple she was real hot
here she was like a real before even the
morgue MILF was a thing like she was
that and she was like like it was the
sisters of the congregation that were
like giving her the side the brothers
like that kids awesome like first of all
he's got a great upper body start with
that at the same haircut for over eight
years
you know wasn't as much a thing for I
remember my dad like I know yeah so
that's the end attendance
that's sex crime descended with a nice
church couple basically a little
may-december romance I mean so then this
is the second story which for some
reason that I don't understand relates
to that story and it shouldn't but when
I got I was like 19 and I got a high
school and I want I didn't go to college
I want to like have a job for some
reason first and I worked at this place
called funcoland which is uh they sell
video it's called GameSpot now I don't
know why I looked at you like you would
know dude this backyard wrestler
understands what I'm saying it's a video
game store okay I know I got hired as
assistant manager right away by this guy
Ricardo let's call him here's his Puerto
Rican guy who's 30 when I was 19 and he
was uh he was also a jehovah's witness
from the spanish congregation okay I
know but he just like we just got along
so he hired me as assistant manager and
I was got a jerk-off you know but uh he
had a violent temper and would yell at
me until I did the job good yeah he was
like really light skinned blue eyed
Berto Rican guy from the island so he
looked down on anybody from here I know
if you know the politics of that of like
Puerto Ricans versus other Rican kind of
people but it's intense and uh well you
were like call me white boy a lot but he
was like very white you know I know and
we would play fighting games and he
would break his controllers because he
thought I was being too cheap because
you cheap me out man why don't you be a
man hey break is control they brought
like three controllers talking like
Mandy Patinkin from The Princess Bride
sorry
you kill my father's anyway so but he
did really man me up I gotta give it to
him and I he end up getting fired for
some but I became the manager and he
trained me so now I'm like 20 and I'm
the manager of fun coal and I look at my
parents I make $24,000 a year so that's
pretty awesome you know uh-huh
I had to hire an assistant manager and
uh the guy that I hired
I'm interviewed a whole bunch of people
and went you know retail with a job like
that you just want to find someone you
could hang out with right that's really
your main how they won't steal too much
and you know that's all you're looking
for because it's a nightmare
you are retail is I like that just that
you know you have the store greeting
great day fun goal and you have to say
that like they think people want that
and then they have snitches that call to
make sure you're telling people you're
having a great day at funk okay
great
yes great leader I'm back so but because
I was religious I was good at that
cottage that stuff you know little
stupid rules for no reason that you have
to follow every guy had training from
the Bible so I hired this guy he was
from Philly this black guy from Philly I
know he was older me too and he was like
he was the first guy I just like got
along with really well okay he was like
pretty hood from life and now you know
now I live in a straight-up ghetto so
it's not new to me now but if you're
from the suburbs that have no one you
know you have maybe black friends if
you're white but they're not like what
you imagine from TV right this is like
hump is the TV comin to work from them
you know it's not all like guys with a
sideways gun there's levels of it
there's like there's hustler guys and
like there's white-collar of that
so he was not he was a smarter so uh
yeah he had been a like an enforcer for
this crack dealer in Philly like he had
to go he told me had to like get people
and uh yeah and I think it's this chick
that I saw in gangland I just put it
together recently pulled the Queen pin
because I'm like as a female as the
timeline works I think that - it was now
looking back um yeah so like if you old
like a small amount of money he would
come just mess you up and uh because you
have to that's how that with that
economy you can't let that go you know
you'll be dead you have to have sendest
sin
let's call him to show Anthony you have
to send a Sean theny let's just mix all
the names together deshawnthony um but
he had been a violin prodigy
okay let's Regan this is story he was a
violin prodigy that tested out of dumb
dumb school that he was in and they put
him in an arts high school cuz he was
like a some kind of mega IQ guy and he
just hung out with bad people and just
dropped out of that school and became a
crackin Ford Center and uh he told me if
he had the reason he moved was he was
going after this one guy who was real
big and he got kind of close the guy the
guy just hit him without warning and
like cracked his rib or something and he
said like he felt like cry is I again
actually I cried a little bit
and then he ran up and like kicked this
dude in the chest and the guy didn't get
up so he moved to my town and worked for
me at phone :
yeah not all this I learned in the
interview by the way did I mention that
this was all told during the interview
process I mean it was riveting there
guys like a Netflix and all that you're
hired right now so always like awesome
hanging out this dude and uh he's into
like martial arts and stuff so he would
like we would go to like flea markets
and buy like it's like hangout Wesley
Snipes really like karate weapons
impractical karate weapons that you
would never use I even show me how to
play with him in like like all kinds of
like stuff that I'm not supposed to do
none of this stuff cuz on a job as
witness I can't play well violent
I couldn't have guns on my Star Wars man
my mom took the guns off my Star Wars
man so I just had men thanks for the man
so finally someone's giving me be some
man time so uh yeah so he some part wait
and he was a great employee
he was like sell all the commissionable
stuff really fast and the customers
loved him because he was a charming dude
he was great
and he was very like supportive like he
was always building up my self-esteem
uh-huh later I work in Jersey City and
these guys I end up getting a fight with
some people I thought they're gonna kill
me cuz that's a bad area and he drove up
with a gun to just watch me like how he
leaves the day he was it down use it
down so he started selling crack on the
side to supplement his Funko and income
okay
it was Bricktown New Jersey so he was
like the only game in town
and uh now he had an enforcer who was
called zoom oh okay I never met him but
just imagine that hearing that name zoom
oh and he he would complain about zoom
Oh like similar smokes too much product
and he's too violent
okay whose beat this guy to death like
cuz he wasn't like a gangster in his
head he was like I'm in Bricktown just a
little side I just held crack to friends
man he wasn't like you know starting an
empire I mean while zoom I was like some
maniac but you always have a new
terrible and this guy deshawnthony had
done some some himself like he told
me a cut a guy's ear off once somebody
had robbed him like he got mugged and
didn't know he's connected to this lady
so her his boys found the guy at a club
and called them over there and he was on
his knees and the alley in the back and
they're standing like God is here off
cut his ear off deshawnthony
I know and we were putting games away
why he's telling me and he goes he goes
yeah I mean I want to do it but you know
they were all yelling so I'm just like
it man I cut his ear off if I put I
was putting away bubsy two for Sega
Genesis otherwise I remember that the
happy cow well better you well it was
just fascinating and I and I you know
I'm a church kid so that's amazing to me
just anything like that so I love
hanging out with them but I was always
like what if you know I don't Moses were
alive and so like you're some weird
Bible II they put your head they
told to imagine Bible characters are
watching him so like with Moses so
well I'm not supposed to be hanging out
with this person okay
at all like a friend like that okay he's
not one of us and he sells crack and he
has a Zuma working for him okay I get
disfellowshipped if somebody found out
that's where you're like out of the
thing that's like disk disconnecting or
whatever right I know so I'm at his
house we're playing with butterfly
knives that we bought when you show me
how to do all the cool I don't want you
all and I could do all that because the
heat this guy showed me and I while I'm
doing that I hear bang bang bang on his
door like a violent that I felt like
someone was coming to get me in trouble
for a night plan like that was such a
nerve-racking sound I know it goes oh
man zeros here I'm sure now I'm in too
deep because I talk to just hang out
with him without ever you know I know
so do it opens up and uh it's
Josh that guy that babysat me and
his teacher in addition to already an
impressive resume by nights he controls
the streets is Uma yeah I not believe it
we both like MIT lead you are here yeah
I don't know hit me I hit that teacher
up getting divorced cuz he's a crackhead
that's that oh that's my story
Thanks